ALICE YANG COLEMAN: Hi.
My name is Alice, and I'm an
engineer on the Glass software
team.
After initial launch
in the United States,
Glass is expanding
to other countries.
I'd like to show you how to make
your GDK Glassware support more
languages and therefore
reach more users.
Here are some basic techniques
for localizing Android GDK
Glassware.
First, make sure
all visible text
is declared in a base
strings.xml file.
You can then refer
to each string
by its name and your Java code.
It's good practice to include
a comment for each string
so your translators have more
context on how it's used.
Once your translations
come back,
simply put them into the
corresponding values directory
for that language.
You can also have different
versions of images, audio,
and video files for
different locales,
but it's better if
the same icon can just
apply to all languages.
That's pretty much
all that's needed.
Piece of cake.
Now, let's look at some
issues you might run into.
One common oversight is using
hard-coded strings in the code.
This will lead to
untranslated text.
Another problem is
translations that
are too long, causing
overlapping text.
You can avoid this by
suggesting a character limit
in your original
strings definition
so translators know
not to exceed it.
One more thing to look out
for is parameters and text.
It may be tempting to simply
concatenate substrings
together.
In this example,
"received at" followed
by the variable 2
followed by o'clock.
But in the Chinese translation,
[SPEAKING CHINESE],
the time variable moved to the
front of the sentence instead.
As shown here, the solution
is to use place holders
in your string definition so
that the entire sentence gets
translated as a whole.
That concludes how GDK
Glassware can be localized.
Once your Glassware
is ready, remember
to submit it to the
Glass team for review.
We look forward to
seeing your submissions,
and thank you for watching.